[Music]
if this gets out we've bought ourselves
a warm
well Arison you said that you wanted to
work with Ryan after seeing a lot of the
work that you've done was there one role
in particular what was it the notebook I
don't think so
no and what I wasn't it's it's
everything I've seen him do was a
challenge well Matt I mean the
discipline to learn all that dancing all
the dance routines the singing and the
keyboard I love the keyboard but also
from place beyond the pines I've been
watching him for years and I really
admire what he's done what is it like to
become friends with somebody who is
probably one of your heroes growing up I
mean to get to work with him was an
incredible opportunity because not only
because you know his movies that meant a
lot to me but because it was an
opportunity to to see how it's done he's
been creating all these seminal movie
experiences for all of us it was the one
person that hasn't got to experience
that because he's been too busy making
them and so to have a window into how he
does that was was a really great
opportunity I want to ask you some
questions
content
[Music]
whoo-hoo how do you show your own kids
your movies like how do you explain to
them or how do they see you first I have
to tie them up and then I have to drag
them into the into a place room where I
could force them to watch it you know my
kids watch my movies according to
whether or not is something they might
be interested right now sixteen-year-old
son just saw the original Blade Runner
few few weeks ago and he's curious and
looking forward to seeing this I that's
what he told me the future of the
species is finally on earth
[Music]
you